good evening a man sentenced to six
years in prison today for crashing into
and killing a teenager in front of his
Henderson Middle School while driving
almost a hundred miles per hour thanks
for joining us at five I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftis there were nearly
200 people in court to support the
victim including his family and his
friends Joshua peguero also inside the
courtroom Joshua was the family
satisfied with that sentence Brian
Denise the family of 13 year old Rex
Patchett says or satisfied the Jose
marmolejo received the maximum sentence
but say there needs to be tougher
penalties they shared how marmolejo
destroyed their family when decided to
drive recklessly near a school
on March 7 2022 I was sentenced to life
in the prison of all prisons I was the
prison of lifelong pain the prison of
lifelong grief the prison of lifelong
fear that statement from Rex patchett's
dad Jason was one of six given by the
teen's family in court Jose Martin
Vallejo showed no emotion as Patch's
family conveyed their pain his body was
so brutally kept so that a visual
confirmation was not even possible the
13 year old was killed in front of
Manion Middle School in Henderson
Patchett was leaving a friend's house
going home for dinner when he was struck
by marmolejo where malejo walked into
the courtroom with a handcuffs and
apologized to the Patchett family I'd
like to give my deepest sorrows
in the end that wasn't enough for the 22
year old to avoid prison time not
judges they're not doing this to send a
message what I'm doing this for is to
try to do equal and exact Justice
between these people in the state of
Nevada and defendant Mr normalejo
leaving the courtroom in handcuffs the
Patchett family says they can now move
on with marmolejo sentenced this is
obviously closure in this phase of the
process right my wife and I are going to
be grieving our children will grieve the
rest of our lives we we will take this
pain with us forever
now marmolejo was sentenced to six years
in prison and has to serve a minimum of
two years after that he's eligible for
parole Brian Joshua thank you Rex patch
his father saying his Focus now will be
to share his story with lawmakers in the
hope that lawmakers can consider
increasing the penalty for drivers who
hit pedestrians